He is forever young
and he has kept us young.
He likes me?
Yes, that’s his way of saying
he’s happy to meet you.
What’s up Doc?
Guess who?
I never thought that someday
I’d be standing here.
What a party!
We’re movie stars.
This is the Oscars.
It's supposed to be formal.
Well, I would explain all
the penguins then.
Nice tux.
Ha. Nice shoes!
One, two, three, five toes?
We're here to present
the award
for Best Animated Short Film
because we're animated
and we are short.
And the envelope loops in.
Whoops, um...
Ride like the wind Bullseye!
The show’s running long.
You forgot something.
And the Oscar goes to...
Hurry up, hurry up.
Alison Snowden
and David Fine
The ChubbChubbs!
Way miserable inside out. Shrek.
Les Misérables
Inside Out
Shrek
Aron Warner
Thank you so much
to The Academy
and everybody out there that supported this film
there were lots of you.
We share this award with you.
If anyone's ever done
this kind of stuff before,
you know it's about
the team,
it's not about the individual.
Now we are very proud of it.
We are really happy right now.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you all!
(As Donald Duck)
Thank you very much.
I love you all.
Thank you. Thank you.
You can make stuff,
make films,
draw, write, it will
make a world of difference.